et erika je vous le dis il ya un
problème
erika elle a deux passions dans la vie
et tout de suite c'est les chaussures
ont été le téléphone c'est les
chaussures et les chaussures et le
téléphone il était une fin a sonné ouais
alors regardez téléphone sonne assez mon
téléphone a répondu mais je le trouve
pas ouais on acquiert wauquiez qui
croient ça c'est mon téléphone alors bon
on enlever votre chaussure pour dave
autre m'a dit un monsieur qui m'a dit au
téléphone il est là dans sa chaussure ah
oui ton répondeur autres chaussures
allez-y on habite à l'eau siason mon
téléphone il est pas là mais ils ont
besoin de votre chaussure mais il m'a
dit ah oui bah oui je vous le dis
dans ma chaussure ouais ouais répondait
c'est bizarre ça ça n'a pas supporté la
partition de conduite à l'hôpital aux
nazis à l'eau vous entendez quelqu'un
c'est le répondeur
alors maintenant à ce qu'on pouvait nous
expliquer comment est ce que vous avez
fait alors avec eric un gel et on a eu
la pause pour tester sur la saga cette
civic est alors j'ai plongé dans un état
de sommeil et avec les quelques minutes
que j'ai eus je lui ai fait accroire que
son téléphone c'était sa chaussure et
quand elle a eu la chaussure un peu plus
tard un peu plus tôt lb des ballons je
vois pas de téléphone [ __ ] téléphone mais
du coup en attendant la sonnerie si ça
lui a replongé allez allez tout cas ça
sonne vous entendez quelqu'un c'est la
candeur et la chausseria johnny on vous
dérange pas ça va je dis ça erika
qu'est-ce qui se passe l'extrait là
qu'on vient de voir
oui en fait la marionnette c'est son
inconscient ouais et lui c'est le mois
et le surmoi donc ouais ouais on
pourrait dire sergent b jeff suppan a
claqué il était éveillée et quand je
l'andorre lui c'est sa conscience à lui
son intellect à lui qui est qui
descendraient qui s'ils sont conscients
jean marc sahi d'accord alors là c'est
quoi qu'est ce que vous avez fait elle
donc elle doit elle répond son téléphone
comme ça
d'accord devant la presse que ce que
répondent bien sûr est ce que vous savez
tu m'appelles non je crois que c'est la
police je vais vous dire a long way et k
avk
oui ça va je dérange pas je te vois
messmer elle elle est toujours dans le
téléphone oui celle du conseil de
fabrique battant fabien boulay c'est
bertrand voit l'appel des crochets
annoncé qu'ils aient vous c'est vous
sirima oui c'est moi bonsoir erika eric
albert vous avez quelque chose à me dire
oui dites moi vous pouvez faire
l'émission de ben oui je suis prévu pour
le moment
vous êtes payées demain je pense non on
ne fait pas payer de bain donc pourquoi
vous m'a appelé pour me dire ça oui
c'est ça merci
pour l'heure ça c'était kiri castet qui
shirin je suis dit 'je me demande si rim
donc vous oui si demain je suis là oui
mais c'est prévu c'est reed et vous
savez quoi à oui est-ce que je peux
avoir une
non
je suis payé demain oui alors et moi
j'ai répondu oui pense oui oui vous avez
dit je suis pas sûr ouais c'est ça ouais
donc sens à payer demain c'est pas grave
merci et bravo françois lozach elle a
quitté nrj 12 qui s'était pas payer
merci à benjamin aussi